DALILA STANFIELD: Advice that
I would give to educators
also planning or hoping to
teach this same kind of course
material or subject would be to
have somebody of the diaspora,
or somebody who can relate
to the diaspora teach it.
It's important to have
people of the background
or of the diaspora
educating others.
Like, who better to
educate than those
that have experienced
it themselves,
or those that, you know,
come from that area.
So I feel like that's
probably the biggest
advice I would give.
I think maybe other advice
would be really making
sure to create safe
spaces for students
to have conversations, because
I feel like we had that
in this class, and that you
can have a curriculum that
can be very diverse, and
like, can be very open.
But if you don't
create an environment
where, like, in which
students can, like, openly
speak about things and openly
talk about things, like,
it's not going to matter.
And I feel like it limits the
kinds of discussions you have.
And I feel like we've had
a lot of great discussions
in this class because the
environment has been--
it's been a safe
environment, you know,
and people can voice
their opinions.
And things have gotten
very personal in this class
sometimes.
You know, there have
been one or two instances
where students got up
and left, you know,
because they were so emotional.
And so, like, yeah.
It's not, it's not just
about the curriculum, too.
It's also about the
space that you create.